So, if you work in an office or anywhere for that matter,...
...and then one day you see a dog walking around,...
...my guess is that the majority of you would get excited.
I know I would.
So, this brings up the idea that maybe pets are good for the workplace.
Now, at first the idea of having a pet at work sounds like it would be a big distraction.
But in fact, a lot of big companies including companies like Google, allow pets at work.
Why is this?
Well, there's a number of reasons,...
...one being that pets lower stress levels.
Now, it's been proven that animals affect the health of hospital patients...
...by lowering blood pressure and helping out with depression.
But did you know that they also tested this theory out in the office?
That's right.
In 2012, Virginia Commonwealth University did a study with 550 office workers.
Some brought their dogs into work every day while others didn't.
By taking surveys and saliva samples,...
...they discovered that the group that did not bring in their dogs to work...
...had a significantly higher stress level at the end of the day than the group that did.